that is why indiana jones is crucial to
the plot of raiders you're only giving
evidence as to why he's crucial to the
plot of finding the thing that they
didn't want to be found if you're
arguing that if they never would have
found the ark they never would have had
these problems you're right they never
would have had these problems and we
wouldn't have a movie called raiders of
the lost ark
hello everyone and welcome back to
another episode of the after show today
we're going to take a look back at the
legacy of the indiana jones franchise
celebrating its iconic placement in
cinema and answering some of the most
popular questions that series has built
up over its run in pop culture today i
am joined by two incredible guests i
have enjoyed speaking movies with them
individually so excited to bring them
together here for the after show first
we have mike kalinowski he's an actor
and author also we have scott mr movie
man he's a film critic folks can find
him at movie man and both of them are
huge indiana jones fans first mike scott
how y'all doing
fantastic very excited to talk about
what could be the greatest quadrilogy of
all time but is it the greatest cloud
trilogy of all time i'm sure gonna
answer that question really fast wow you
know what
wow i think a lot of films are gonna
enter the chat to like
come at you on that one but
i i do appreciate your love and
affection for all of it including the
fourth uh mike sir how about you how are
you doing today i was gonna say we're
gonna talk about the greatest trilogy of
all time but uh
we can't toy story can't be talked about
anymore because of the fourth one
dropped in there so i will defer to the
group and uh talk about crystal skull as
well let's go ahead and start with uh
the brass tacks we're talking about
these four in individual films all of
them were directed by steven spielberg
raiders of the lost ark which is
certified fresh at 95 with the audience
score of 96 temple of dune certified
fresh at 84 audience score of 81. the
last crusade certified fresh at 88
with an audience score of 94 and the
kingdom of the crystal skull certified
fresh at 78 percent bringing up the rear
of the franchise and an audience score
53 because folks were
upset about that fourth installment
scott mance is not one of them this
leaves the franchise with an average
rating of 86 percent on the tomato meter
and 81 in the audience score this is
something that i think the dc eu would
literally hand over other bonuses to get
that kind of a cumulative rating
uh but this is what's crazy so ladies
and gentlemen we have
indiana jones in the chat today let's
talk about it
uh
yeah it was temple of doom that's the
movie that i remember the member of the
theater at the coral springs mall
and i saw it with my mom and i walked
out of that movie theater and go that's
what i want to do that's what i want to
do when i grow up and my mom's kind of
like like like an archaeologist and i
was like trying to make the distinctions
no i want to be an actor
so that's the movie that i i credit to
being an actor 2003 i got cast in the
role and then for about 10 years i
played indiana jones at uh the disney
mgm studios so
did you have to keep running running
away from that boulder every single
that's my favorite part of that show and
uh if you've seen the show it's divided
into three acts kind of based on the
movie and after the first scene you're
an indie by yourself stealing the the
fertility idol and i come down and the
sets are kind of being broken apart and
this is where the actors and the extras
are brought on stage and one of the cast
comes up he's like hey you nervous
and i'm like nah i've done this show for
years now say go look in vip
and i look in vip and there i see that
familiar gray beard and the flannel
shirt
at the time and then george lucas was
sitting in the audience with his family
and then
i don't know if you could see this
picture
that's me during the show
after the show
oh wow
that is awesome awesome
and then later in life this guy came
along and now this is indiana bones
right here
raiders of the lost ark
a film from steven spielberg and george
lucas
let's go ahead and bring it over to
raiders the critics consensus for
raiders of the lost ark says featuring a
brother of set pieces sly humor and
white knuckle action raiders of the lost
ark is one of the most consummately
entertaining adventure pictures of all
time is is raiders the best of the
quadrilogy i mean of course it is it's a
masterpiece even steven spielberg said
it is a perfect movie it was nominated
for best director it was nominated for
best picture raiders of the lost ark was
nominated for best picture do either of
you know without looking it up what
movie did raiders of the lost ark lose
best picture to
raiders of the lost ark i have to think
of what year it is and then i'm trying
to think so 80
89 was last crusade right right 81 is
raiders right
is it true it's a fire it is cherry it's
a fire way to go that's a good job well
you guys that says that's movie trivia
scott that's much more down there
because this is what i have to do with
best pictures i have to count them
backwards like i have to literally start
with the ones that are today and go
backwards with them with the naming
thing yeah i don't do the damn showdown
ridiculous
well various of the lost star did win
four academy awards for art and set
direction sound film editing and visual
effects and it was made on a budget of
18 that's 1 8 18 million dollars and it
grossed and at the time in 1981 390
million dollars worldwide but you know
getting
getting past all of the statistics which
are of course really fascinating
the thing about raiders is that you
could have made that movie today and it
would it would have looked and felt
exactly the same even though it takes
place in 1936 it has a timeless
feel to it nothing about it in terms of
its movie making in terms of its
structure in terms of the actors and the
screenplay in the direction none of it
feels dated at all it is still just as
exciting as fun as exhilarating and even
as spiritual because of the whole thing
with the with the ark
it still feels vital and current you
know more than 40 years later that's why
i it is it is the best of the bunch mike
so now that we're now we've sort of
started into raiders what is your
favorite moment from raiders because
again it's such an iconic entry in the
series it's what kicked it off it's a
lot of people's favorite
uh well the whole opening temple scene
is wonderful but as i'm getting older
then what i gravitate to which sticks to
me is just the whole bit of you know
it's not the year sweetheart it's the
mileage not the man i knew 10 years ago
it's the mileage
like i feel that in my body every day uh
and and it just
it just it sums up the character the
dialogue the script is so tight and and
stuff you know so much about indy and
just these little nods so that to me
just as indiana jones and what i think
about him so scene-wise it's that
opening temple but that whole scene with
him and marion where she's you know
where does it hurt here here here yeah
that's great i just love it it's just
such a perfect film perfect yep
300
i will admit i loved the big bang theory
episode where they talked about the
stupidity of indiana jones which i know
originated on reddit which is this is
the thing with raiders the lost art it
is an
incredible movie folks love it
especially
but
he doesn't matter indiana jones plays no
role in the outcome of the story like if
he weren't in the film it would turn out
exactly the same the nazis would have
still found the ark taken it to the
island opened it up and all died just
like they did
look at look at scott's face scott
is just like
wrong
that is absolutely false
absolutely false i i know scott's dying
for this how like give me the what's the
evidence that it's false would they know
okay i'm gonna defer to scott and then
i'm gonna chime in with scott because i
know he wants to i have been
up all night yeah i know i know wait to
answer this question that is not true
and here's the proof
the nazis mike and jacqueline
what were they doing
they were in the wrong place they were
digging in the wrong place exactly mike
and why were they digging in the wrong
place because the staff that they were
using for the for the the staff of ra
was too long so they would not have
found the ark
it was indiana jones
who found the ark that is why indiana
jones is crucial to the plot of raiders
you're only giving evidence as to why
he's crucial to the plot of finding the
thing that they didn't want to be found
so how is he crucial to the plot of
saving the world to your point you said
the nazis would have never found the ark
if the nazis never find the ark for
purposes of our of our saving the world
the world gets saved at that point
because they didn't find the ark
the only reason why they wait the only
reason why they found the ark was
because indiana jones directed them to
it so yes that makes him consequential
that makes consequential to the part of
effing it up not to the part of saving
the world but the question is and this
is this is what they brought up in the
big bang theory the issue the debate is
is does
indiana jones matter to the plot of this
movie and amy from big bang theory is
saying no he doesn't and i'm saying yes
he does tell me how the world does not
get saved without indie and i think
exactly
i think that point jacqueline is is the
fact of like you know the no way home
argument spider-man's like yeah mysterio
or doctor strange could have wiped out
mysterio's memory instead of what he did
in the movie to have a movie we don't
have a movie then if you're arguing that
if they never would have found the ark
they never would have had these problems
you're right they never would have had
these problems and we wouldn't have a
movie called raiders of the lost ark
scott i'm not going to debate you on
that one all i will say is
there is an argument also to be made
that if he would have just sat there and
ate his food
real quick though
marian's um
only performance and i have to give her
like buku credit because
when i went back and revisited the other
one she was such a refreshing thing for
me in comparison to temple of doom the
protagonist and that who's
that's dude still works wife isn't it
yeah
will burke's wife that's where they met
i agree with you completely jacqueline
uh karen allen as mariam ravenwood in
raiders of the lost ark
is such
a big reason
why
raiders of the lost ark is the best
movie of the bunch because among the
many reasons why raiders feel so
timeless
you have this character a woman who is
indiana jones's equal
she gave as good as she got she was on
his level she was just as smart as he
was she was just as strong as he
was i learned to hate you in the last 10
years
i never meant to hurt you i was a child
i was in love
it was wrong and you knew it you knew
what you were doing now i do this is my
place get out the two of them harrison
ford and karen allen had amazing
chemistry together and i just they were
a great great great team and but back in
1981 a character like that was was few
and far between now
it's different and that's another reason
why raiders of the lost ark
holds up and it still feels so current
because you have such a strong character
like marion ravenwood she's great
what's what's so great about raiders
what i think is interesting about
raiders is raiders is a big budget
version of the old superman
uh remember the old superman episodic
with george with the cliffhanger yeah
with yeah like that that's exactly what
indiana jones is and and and marion is
his lowest lane
and so that's why this one i felt
especially raiders had so much that it
borrowed from what donner was able to do
when he put superman on the big screen
and sort of translated that episodic
serial into it let's move on to the
temple of doom
if adventure has a name
it must be
indiana jones
critic's consensus for this one it may
be too dark for some but indiana jones
and the temple of dune remains an
ingenious adventure spectacle that
showcases one of hollywood's finest
filmmaking teams in vintage form all
right so
is it india is it the temple of doom
that gave us pg-13 is this correct that
is correct jacqueline yeah two movies
that came out in 1984 led to the
creation of the pg-13 rating one of them
you are absolutely 100 correct indiana
jones and the temple of doom is one of
the films
uh mike or jacqueline do you know the
second movie that led to the creation of
people no trivia master i knew that
first answer i'm not participating okay
i'm going to i'm going to
grab less
do less
is it gremlin
gremlins
mike you are on fire my friend yeah yeah
rambling so so so basically
steven spielberg is the reason why we
have pg-13 because he directed indiana
jones in the temple of doom and he
produced gremlins so thank you steven
spielberg for g13 what about you though
uh mike what's your favorite moment from
temple of dude it's got a lot of
variance oh man
i mean the opening scene him and that
white tux like you know and again a lot
of people like uh spielberg was
originally courted he wanted to do a
bond film that was his big thing he
wanted to do a bond film and they just
with the broccoli cubby broccoli and
harry salsm at the time they just never
clicked this was kind of pre-jaws too
with him when they were looking at him
and lucas you know came up was like hey
i got this character indiana smith
you know it's kind of my take on bond
it's like these great franchises and
great things that we have for films came
from them not being able to do other
franchises like flash gordon or james
bond so we get indy and this to me
brought a lot of james bond with the
white talks looking like john connery
and goldfinger they do the whole scene
and the gong and the rolling behind the
thing is the bullets and they go out the
window and
it's just that opening scene is just
phenomenal
nice try laosha
[Music]
and i know willie scott gets a lot of
flack
willie's important because you
understand why indy should be with
marion like you knew him and willie were
never going to be together
but they set up the fact that oh he need
marion is him that's
they need to be together so i really
like marion
or i'm sorry willie like for that reason
um short round
like yeah short round's great like i
don't even want to call him a sidekick
but he's awesome
hey doctor joe no it's time for love
we've got company
we're gonna get into short round and
then also to
the other aspects because look for not
just the darker tone there was other
aspects of it that under closer
expression some people have really
looked at the way it portrayed
indigenous peoples in this movie and and
those stereotypes unfortunately people
remember that still to this day it's one
of the things that people associate you
know indigenous like that's how we got
words like savage is from imagery like
this that that sort of permeated
throughout culture that allows people to
think that these people's traditions and
thoughts are savage when meanwhile you
know
getting someone to explain it's like oh
yeah you know
christian communion we're eating the
body of a dead person it's like well you
know looking at that from a certain lens
some people you know what i'm saying and
stuff
you're very right you're very right yeah
we need to give a little bit of credence
to the fact that there were aspects and
including short round um just this idea
of the sort of not disposable short
round was a huge part of this plot but
disposable in the franchise he doesn't
show up again uh sidekick minority
character who's there just in literal
service of the white main character
don't think that's the same kind of
indiana jones story we'd see today
scott i know you have feelings on willie
so
well first of all
you know
my god
i get that indiana jones and the temple
with them takes place the year before so
indy had not yet been reunited with
marion ravenwood
but
to go chronologically from movie to
movie
to go from marion in raiders to willie
scott in temple of doom
i mean she's so grating she screams
71 times i mean
biggest struggle with her is the noise
for the love of god but i will say this
about temple with doom it is absolutely
far and away
my favorite of the sequels i don't think
it's better than raiders of the lost ark
but i do have to say that when i go back
and watch one of these four movies
temple of doom is the one that i watch
the most even though
you know willie scott is kind of a kind
of annoying but this movie where the
first movie cost 18 million dollars the
second film temple of doom cost 28
million dollars and it grossed 333
million dollars worldwide it won only
one academy award for visual effects it
was also nominated for john williams
amazing score and i think john williams
scores the best uh of all the sequels
not better than the original
but one of the things that makes temple
of doom probably the the best movie to
watch
is the villain
malaram
is the best villain in any of these four
movies and uh amish pury who played
moaram was so great in the film that you
forget that he doesn't even show up
until halfway through the movie it feels
like he's there the whole time
but he is fantastic and the first 15
minutes of this movie
indiana jones gets poison he he's in a a
fight a club obi-wan he jumps out the
window there's a car chase to the
airport with guns fighting and then you
know he gets on the plane
nice try lashay they fly off and he
jumps out the way off the plane with
which short round and a raft and they
fall down and
and go uh down the side of a mountain
into
into the rapids i mean there's so much
going on just in the first 15 minutes of
this movie quick thought
just real quick answer
could it happen or is this literally we
gotta just suspend disbelief on the
inflatable raft mike go suspend
disbelief
or you're in it when you watch suspend
disbelief yeah you gotta you gotta
suspend disbelief on that one you
seeking like a rock you're not doing
anything all movies are suspend
disbelief but that one yeah you're right
i'm like this is like they wouldn't even
do this on a disney ride uh scott
uh you know of course you gotta suspend
this belief i mean from the moment this
movie opens you got to suspend this
belief and i think that just goes with
the territory for the indiana jones
movies but at the same time i i feel
like the jumping out of the plane with
the wrath and like wrapping it around
and it you know inflating it while
they're falling so they have a soft
landing on the snow
i don't think that's out of the realm of
plausibility i went with a a stunt like
that
much much better than i went with let's
say you want to talk a preposterous
stunt
fast and furious nine
when vin diesel is in his car and they
they go swinging in the car over the
ravine
i i like now that's preposterous that is
like ridiculous so it's so bad it takes
you out of the movie but you can say
that about any of the fast and furious
movies but again
[Laughter]
i'm glad you guys mentioned this this is
the american james bond that's exploring
the frontier of lost artifacts and so on
and so forth
it's one of the reasons why i give willy
a little bit of a pass because one i
feel like her character
is meant to be that way because the two
men involved in the creation of this
were very out on women at the beginning
of this i mean george lucas talks about
his divorce steven spielberg talks about
his really bad breakup
and they're both in a place where
poking fun or making a simplistic woman
that they can manipulate and torture a
little bit over the course of this film
because let's not pretend she's
screaming for a reason all of this stuff
is insane granted my reaction would be
side eyes and smart remarks
but everybody's going to have a reaction
to the insanity of people pulling hearts
out of chats let's be real and gigantic
spiders and getting falling out of
planes and stuff like this is not like
stuff that you're supposed to be like
i'm just going to look at my manicure no
she's a hollywood movie star but she's
pampered beyond reproach so
i appreciate her for showing the
reaction that
99.9 of people will have so let that
girl have her moment those girls are
real those girls are real and if they
were caught up in the hijinks of james
bond or in this case indiana jones
that's what they would do let's go ahead
and move forward to my favorite indie
indiana jones is on the quest of a
lifetime
but for some adventures
[Music]
one jones is not enough dad junior don't
call me that please
the last crusade um the kurdix consensus
is that it's lighter and more comedic
than its predecessors indeed and indiana
jones the last crusade returns the
series to the brisk cereal adventures of
raiders while adding a dynamite double
act between harrison ford and sean
connery
omg do i love this movie i love it love
it love it so much i love it for how
funny it is and it had me river phoenix
and oh that part's great yeah he opens
up this movie and i loved it i loved how
they tried to explain his scar
i loved just that that that shot where
you see the head down and up i love sean
connery as a younger version of himself
like grand and different saying no in
latin and shut up
uh yeah it's probably oh god i love that
i even watched the show that they made
as an extension of this young indiana
jones i watched that religiously uh
mance i have a feeling you're going to
break my pride right now and tell me
that you don't like this movie oh well
first of all jaclyn i completely
understand this is the first movie that
introduced you to indiana jones of
course you're going to love it and i
completely respect that but here's the
thing jacqueline i have to say that even
though i do like last crusade i think
it's very entertaining it is a distant
third to temple of doom once you get
past the part with river phoenix which i
think is the best part of the movie i
just feel like it's they they tried to
play it safe after all the criticism
they got for temple of doom being too
dark and too violent they tried to
replicate the structure of raiders of
the lost ark for the first like third of
the movie
i think that that last crusade is
actually a weak film
until
sean connery shows up as henry jones
then it gets good and the reason it gets
good is because the two of them have
amazing chemistry that's what
invigorates this film and invigorates
the franchise takes it in a different
direction dad
oh dad ah dad what
head for the fireplace
but overall i think that while rey is
the raiders of the lost ark the
production values of that movie are
timeless
i feel like last crusade is too slick
it's too polished the nazis and raiders
felt dangerous to me the nazis in last
crusade felt like keystone cops it was a
little just too cartoony compared to the
first two movies i i love it and i think
the last part of the movie where again
indiana jones is using his brains to get
to the holy grail and he chose
wisely uh last crusade just it's it's
just third on my list a distant third
sorry that's such a shame
it's such a good time
the nazi heifer talks in her sleep and
sean connie was finding it out how did
you know she was a nazi
she talks in sleep
mike what about you please you don't
think he's laying
i will never disparage uh last crusade
because it is a great film but like as i
was listening to scott and he
articulated much better the way that i
was feeling i couldn't put to words
about the slick and polished to me i'd
always said last crusade to me feels
like return of the jedi
everything is so polished and it's so
clean and it it feels i always said with
raiders lost or sorry uh return of the
jedi it felt very kenner toyish which
was the toys at the time and like this
movie the the nazis they do
they don't feel dangerous like they felt
in in raiders and the special effects
are they try to push the envelope so i
think they looked even
that movie does not hold up as well as
raiders does now like a lot of the plane
sequence stuff looks very
late 80s special effects whereas raiders
was less money they had no money to do
the effects they were doing everything
you know practically and
it just but again you've got the
relationship with him and his father
that that's the core of the movie
and that so much and i love elsa
schneider
allison duty
i love walter donovan in there um
like these characters are great you know
the whole marcus brody bringing marcus
brodie and with saul and getting
everyone together and seeing solo just
be
seeing marcus be
incompetent brody's got friends in every
town and village from here to the sudan
he speaks a dozen languages knows every
local custom he'll blend in disappear
you'll never see him again
with any luck he's got the grill already
how does anyone here speak english or
even ancient greek
well that's the other thing mike is that
marcus brody like like when you watch
him he's only in a little bit of raiders
of the lost ark and he's hilarious
and but but he's he's on he's on andy's
level
with the lost star look what i mean i
love that they gave denim elliott more
screen time and they like he went with
him basically it was part of the action
but he was a buffoon yeah and and i felt
like
yeah i mean at the time when i saw it in
1989 i was uh 21 yeah a little bit older
than you going yeah but uh but i do feel
i i was like really that's what you're
gonna do to marcus brody i don't think
that last crusade has aged well even
though it did gross 474 million dollars
on a budget of 48 million dollars and it
also won an academy award for visual
effects and two other oscar nominations
for sound and of course original score
i loved it i loved it i loved every
aspect of it and
you can't have
i think you can't have it you have to
infantize
you have to infantize indy because you
have to bring in his father and that is
always going to infantize whoever it is
okay mike mike you just brought up you
know just sort of going on my initial
criticism about last crusade describing
last crusade as the return of the jedi
of the indiana jones series is extremely
accurate it was a step down so if if
raiders of the law if temple of doom is
is the empire strikes back
something that was really really dark
and very mature for grown-ups then you
had the the uh the way that last crusade
just sort of made it like kid friendly
yeah um i'm not down with that uh and
that's a big problem why i think that
that return of the jedi is is the worst
star wars movie of them all yes wow on
that hill i know i'm gonna get a lot a
lot of flack for that but that's just
the truth
you know once you see those stupid
little ewok thief walk towards leia i'm
like hell no click
yeah
i don't think you're as alone as you
think you are last crusade i think
there's a huge majority of people that
love that film and it's their favorite i
mean i don't disagree but i will say
like i hate to like bring it and make it
a generational divide because i feel
like there it is but like legitimately
basically if you're my if you're in that
like elder millennial age you feel a
certain way about it and if you are in
gen x you feel a certain way about it
and then like anybody after us doesn't
care
scott said it best it's like with bond
like where you first see bond like i was
with scott i saw roger moore he was my
bond i don't have the affinity for
connor even though i know his film
started it i don't have that affinity
when i say that country's not my
favorite bond people lose their mind uh
we're gonna fast forward a little bit
because i definitely want to give the
fourth installment its day in the sun
lord knows that things get cleansed with
light
so
let's go ahead and bring it into our
fourth installment indiana jones and the
crystal skull what's he gonna do now i
don't think he plans that far ahead oh
i'd cover my ears if i were you
critics consensus though the plot
elements are certainly familiar indiana
jones and the crystal skull still
delivers the thrills and harrison's
boards return in the title role is more
than welcome
gonna go ahead and do a little
self-serving cross promotion right now
if you want to go see my in-depth
rolling my eyes so hard i think i may
have made them not pop back you can
watch me and scott talking about this
very movie on the rotten tomatoes the
strong podcast where i have made it
very clear
oh this movie i remember
this movie and it's and as last
crusade was one in the opening moments
this movie was lost in the opening
moments as those rambunctious white
children drove where the hell they did
not need to drive
i was alright
for those kids in that opening
well to this day
indiana jones and the kingdom of the
crystal skull has the biggest budget
that steven spielberg has ever worked
with on a feature film 185 million
dollars
endorsement and wait but what is a
ringing endorsement is that the movie
made 791
million dollars worldwide that's uh more
than twice of what raiders made uh and
and two to the point jacqueline the
smoothie it's the first indiana jones
film to get no academy award nominations
at all and it is also the first indiana
jones movie to win a razzy award for
worst prequel remake ripoff or sequel
now i get the hate you know when i saw
this movie in 2008 i was just excited to
see to see indiana jones back on the big
screen
uh i did not feel like it was as good as
the first three movies
it is my least favorite of the four but
i still think it has its merits i don't
think that crystal skull is flat out
bad like the star wars prequel trilogy
and yes the star wars sequel trilogy i
think that is better than those movies i
think it has its merits i think the
beginning of the film the fight in the
warehouse is great
i know that people have problems with
the refrigerator scene but if you're
going to suspend this belief by watching
indiana jones jump out of a plane with a
with a raft then you gotta suspend
disbelief by having him hide in a
refrigerator during a nuclear blast i
thought that scene was awesome i loved
it come on
i'm with you scott i like you said you
suspend this belief like okay all right
it is light suspension of disbelief to
believe that you could cushion a fall
like that it is a suspension beyond
belief and into science fiction to think
that somebody can survive a nuclear
holocaust because
to to to uh uh just for you know since
we're throwing out trivia that the
refrigerator scene was actually a nod to
back to the future because back when
they were developing back to the future
the time machine was not a
silver delorean the time machine was a
refrigerator so i thought really
yes
just how ridiculous it is there's a
great john mulaney bit about how it must
have been to try and pitch back to the
future to tv executives
so this high schooler is is friends with
the disgraced nuclear physicists
how old is the physicist nobody knows
how old
how did they become friends
nobody knows
why
nobody you know it's like
this is what it is
i'm with you in the sense that the
opening film i should have kind of
sensed what we were in for but it was
more so that the kids you know was there
listen to hound dog it was the cgi mole
hill with the cgi mole coming out trying
to recreate the raiders with the
mountain and just like
oh well what are we in for here like the
cgi that i'm like okay you and this film
i think it had been shot digitally
because it just doesn't
look with that film as that it doesn't
have
and films that are made today can
recreate films that were shot back then
to have that same kind of stock and
grain and and just
something just felt weird the wash of
the film
everything like it was a haze to it that
didn't help yeah so
and i went in with this and i went in
with this film like gosh just i had my
fedora on i had everything all set like
this was the film was gonna be indiana
jones back in the big screen the
trailers had led us to believe that this
was going to be incredible and like
scott said like the warehouse beginning
the area 51 i enjoy that
i enjoy him missing over you know he's
whipping and he over overestimates his
leap and it goes back into the truck and
you know max like you know
he says something about indiana jones
like he said something's like no no no
you don't do that don't know it you
don't know him you don't know him
so the indy that we were new in last
crusade he was there but then it just
kind of goes off the rails after that
you know the the when when you have the
nuclear blast
and indy gets out of the of the fridge
and he's the camera is like below his
waist
and the camera is pointing up
and you see indy look at this big
mushroom cloud
and then he looks down
the world is different
it is not like the indiana jones we saw
in the 30s with those first three movies
it's just to say like
either you're going to adapt to the
nuclear age in the or you're going to be
left behind yeah adapt or die
adapt or die now there are things about
a crystal skull i don't like the
swinging monkeys uh i think that's
ridiculous and i love king blanchett
two-time uh oscar winner cate blanchett
i i love her immensely as an actress
uh her accent in this movie is leaves a
lot to be desired but
i still think uh crystal skull on its
own merits is still fun when i rewatched
it jaclyn when i re-watched it for that
rotten tomatoes is wrong discussion that
we had i was surprised by how much it
actually does hold up now if you're
going to compare it and hold it to the
standards of the first three movies
which of course you're going to have to
do because they're all part of the same
series they're all part of the same quad
trilogy then of course you're going to
see a drop in quality but i don't think
it's as bad as people say i think it
still holds up i think it has aged
pretty well and i think people who hate
the film if you haven't seen it in a
while go back and watch it again i think
it's on paramount plus and you'll see
that you know maybe
maybe it's not so bad
what's going to be interesting with this
one i do feel with crystal skull in
particular
it's sort of like working with george
their friendship he defers to him a lot
and i know george wanted to go to space
and aliens with indy and it was
something that i think spielberg fought
in the first you know iterations was
getting too outlandish and i think when
they sort of like you know
they became friends like okay well we're
gonna do it your way this time right i
have a feeling um if we turn to indy 5
one of the things that i think and i
hope is i want steven spielberg when he
operates from sentimentality which is
weird when i say this not nostalgia
sentimentality when steven spielberg
operates from symptom mentality he's the
worst director and i'm not saying he's
bad director i'm saying he's the first
version of himself as director since
mentality is indiana jones and the
crystal skull uh sentimentality is hook
and so
i just hope that he removes his
sentimentality for indie five and he
works more the way that he did with west
side story which is take your love for
this thing but realize that you're going
to have to make adjustments to make it
into something great and i think we have
really a lot to look forward to mike
what about you what are you looking
forward to and hopefully indy 5.
um i'll say this
after crystal skull i was kind of
not put off i was like all right that
really shouldn't have happened and i'm
one of those guys i don't want to see a
new actor in the role
like to me harrison ford is indiana
jones and people did for a while there
was chris pratt talk and
um i i don't
know if i want to see another indiana
jones wild harrison ford so when they
announced this one and then for a while
their spielberg was attached to it
and then i was like i don't know he's
harrison ford was great in this and he's
graded han solo in force awakens and he
proved he still looks great
but then the change for me was mangled
when mangle was brought on yeah and what
he did with logan
and gave a fitting swan song to this man
that has played this role for
you know 9 11 films for
20 years now he's like okay
yeah so now i'm like okay now i feel
better
in the
with what's gonna happen and now you
wanna say i'm almost more excited like
okay they're gonna give india fitting
end this is gonna be it harrison ford's
come back one more time
you know they'll learn their lessons
with what they did less cgi monkeys i
hope like mutt doesn't show up i think
that was such a poor choice
and not the fact of indy having his son
is a bad choice it was just the casting
of shia at the time he was the guy you
know the young actor at the time they it
just didn't work
so
i'm cautiously optimistic going forward
well here's the thing first of all
you hit the head now on the head mike
because
when they first announced indiana jones
five my feeling was
i look indiana jones four
okay you have one film that's weak
well let's let's just leave it at that
if you have another week indiana jones
movie you're going to dilute the
franchise and that's the last thing
anybody wants is to see the quality of
the overall series brought down with a
fifth movie uh that that and one that
that god forbid isn't isn't good
but what turned me around what got me
excited about indiana jones 5. like you
pointed out mike is that spielberg is
not directing it the director for indy 5
is going to be james mangled who not
only did a great job with logan i mean
he did an amazing job with logan but
you're talking about a director who has
done basically every movie he does is in
a different genre
copland was a cop drama uh walk the line
uh the the story about uh june carter
and johnny cash from 2005 is fantastic
and of course logan is great and i loved
ford versus ferrari from 2019. all these
movies are from different types of
genres so i think if anybody is going to
really steer indiana jones back into
being a like sort of end them on a high
note here and really do away with the
swinging monkeys
and the flying saucers it's going to be
james mangle there's no way that he's i
i just have
weird to say
jaclyn and mike but i have more faith
than james mangle directing an indiana
jones movie then then spielberg because
of what you said jacqueline about how
when he leans into sentimentality you
get movies like hook which i think is
the worst stephen spielberg movie i mean
i love hook i'm not saying that it's a
bad movie as far as enjoyment i'm just
saying that is a bad movie as far as
filmmaking that he is capable of look
uh
the movie that he made after um
schindler's list was jurassic
world the lost world and it was because
he could not emotionally invest in
another movie after doing schindler's
list as the jewish man writing that
story making that story having to go
through an entire season of talking
about it because of oscars was just too
much for him and so he wanted to do
something sentimental and familiar and
we get the lost world
the question begs i guess scott since
you've already i think sort of said it
the i guess you think this is the best
quadrilogy i have to say jackass has
entered the chat and having seen now all
four of those i
know that you're wrong because that is
those four movies there's not a week
there's not a weak note in the band that
is four movies of awesome and grad and
bad grandpa is like a nice little amuse
boosh
so is it the greatest quadrilogy of all
time well it definitely has a run for
its money in terms of mad max
all four of those movies are great and
you know the fourth one
is absolutely fantastic fury road i mean
uh for a fourth film in a in a
quadrilogy i mean that's what makes that
series great so is it the best uh i
think it's one of the best but i don't
know i kind of think that mad max might
actually be better because
all four of those movies are just
perfect you know what i'm gonna go on
the limb being a dc guy and i'm gonna
say the original four that they kind of
lumped together burton and schumacher's
they kind of grouped that they always
put it in a four pack of blu-rays
together they stick that on the 4k
four-pack together you know that's kind
of like the 90s batman uh-uh schumacher
you're talking about a girl going hey
they told the 60s batman show and wanted
to make a live action version of that it
works and clooney clooney's got charm
for days like i'm not on the toy story
train
people love those films toy story i'm
not on that train but mad max
i didn't think about that
i'm thinking just like you know live
action here but toy story is also up
there and definitely i mean all four of
those movies are great the first three
are absolutely great
and i mean the first one was it was the
first computer animated feature film
ever made back in 1995 and the fourth
that the third one
uh was nominated for best picture and it
was the best of of all four movies but
because it was because it's animated i
don't think of it on the same level as
like you know mad max or indiana jones
but mike with the batman quadrilogy
there but
batman and robin just doesn't do it for
me and batman returns i i think that
movie
has aged well
but it's like those four movies are like
a roller coaster you got the the first
one and the second one then the third
one and then the fourth one you know
it's it's all over the place
yeah yeah
hey they took big swings they didn't
always land on those ones but as a whole
and now looking back at them like you
know it was a time period of the 90s and
but
that's yeah that's what i have to go but
the mad max that's a good one i didn't
think about it mad max is a really good
one i stand by jackass
but i agree before we leave i guess my
last question to you guys is what do you
think would be
the best example of sort of like that
indie style movie and there's so many
examples i mean you have lara croft both
versions you have the uncharted coming
up on it but then you also have like i
would say more under the radar type
stuff like romancing the stone and
treasure
uh planet and goonies and then there's
stuff too that people forget which i
think are very good like fool's gold and
national treasure uh what do you think
is the best indiana jones
film riff-off or film that sort of riffs
on that sort of like trying to find
trying to find treasure uh film and mike
i'll start with you another thing about
it maybe that was maybe that's why
raiders is so great because
there's been many imitators but nothing
has gone like yeah that's like i know
people love national treasure i can't
get behind those movies i've tried
listen you know
mike
yeah i i enjoyed the first national
treasure it came out in 2004 i think uh
was romancing the stone if you're
looking at a standalone film right i
would say
romancing romancing the stone from 1984
is is the one that's on the level but
well on the level raiders not quite
there but close enough in terms of
franchises of course you know the mummy
starring brendan fraser you know those
movies are a lot of fun i i'm good one
you know uh and and look the reason why
i'm saying that the the uh the mummy
series is actually
a worthy
uh sort of successor is because i'm
leaning into the word ripoff and those
movies are such a blatant ripoff of the
indiana jones series that they lean into
the fact that they are a ripoff that is
a self-aware film series it knows what
it's ripping off and it goes with it and
i think that's actually one of the
charms
of those movies of course rachel vice is
terrific and sort of like the marion
ravenwood role apparently frasier was
very very good but another film that is
often overlooked and i don't even know
if a lot of people even
know about this movie
came out in 2005 it's called duma
duma is about a relationship between a
young a young kid and his cheetah who he
named duma
and they go off on this adventure and
it's very very much like indiana jones
trust me and let me know what you think
i love this movie it's wonderful
my favorite one that
since you took the mummy i'll say this
not the movies but the books
that dan brown did
with robert landon are actually quite
incredible in that adventure seeking
treasure type thing robert landon
is a
smart man's indiana jones okay yeah yeah
i mean how much actually angels are
demons
is the best of it and that was what's so
crazy about is it got the worst
reputation but it's actually the best of
it and yeah angels and demons is also
the best book for folks that don't know
anyway
moving moving out of the dan brown
literary agency and going ahead and
wrapping up the after show gentlemen
this was such a great conversation thank
you thank you thank you so much uh
i let folks know where they can find you
uh scott and what so just follow me on
twitter and instagram and again watch
duma and then hit me up on twitter at
moviemance let me know what you think of
this wonderful film watch it with the
whole family i promise you will not be
sorry
all right mike sir what you working on
working folks find you uh at mike
kalonowski on all my social media i got
uh my very first book will be out in
bookstores uh a genuine february 15th
it's bond james bond exploring the
shaken and stirred history of
ianflemings007
uh it's my first book with a man named
brad gilmore who wrote a book on back to
the future uh kind of best-selling book
on back to the future brought me on
because of my love of james bond and now
it's funny we were talking we're doing
kind of a series of podcasts and we're
just we're talking about indiana jones
and he goes huh and that should be our
next book so
now
you talking to the two of you guys here
it just got it's such a
these two franchises bond and especially
indiana jones are just so kind of
it's just you know they've been so with
us for so long and they're so beloved
and and we all have our stories and love
of them and i think
it's uh it's wonderful i'd love to talk
with you guys so thanks for letting me
have uh be here with you guys yeah
thanks so much this is a great
conversation thank you oh great all
right that's it for us uh this week
again i'm jaclyn you can find me
everywhere at that jaclyn and we'll see
all of you next time
on the after show
you